avec nous maintenant clément gignac
économistes et sénateurs ip mia homsy
pdg de l'institut du québec bonsoir à
vous deux ans soit le niveau d'inflation
est encore plus élevé qu'attendu on
disait 7,7 pour cent que les mots gignac
les économistes la nationale 10
aujourd'hui que l'inflation est hors de
contrôle qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais tout allait certainement pas ce
contrôle ne parlait le mois dernier
ensemble que l'inflation sont ni récent
de temps aux 8% maintenant si ce que les
économistes prédisent également je pense
que c est là qu on le voit également aux
états unis avaient toutes les
développements qu'on voit à l'échelle
internationale la poussée des prix des
matières premières et l'or maintenant
les salaires quand on commence embarquer
là-dedans que finalement on est on ne
peut pas encore le contrôle est ce ça
veut dire plus de hausses de taux
d'intérêt est évidemment oui il ya aussi
tout le montant le vu l'inflation est
vraiment généralisée est ce que le seul
moyen de contrer cette inflation qui
galope et qui donne l'impression
effectivement des torts hors contrôle
c'est une forte hausse des taux
d'intérêt
il ya deux causes le compare l'inflation
faut regarder l'offre et la demande donc
avec évidemment on augmente les taux
d'intérêt l'objectif des banques
centrales c'est de ralentir la demande
et donc que les gens consomment moins
pour enlever de la pression mais il ya
une énorme partie aussi qui vient du
côté de l'offre et donc sur ça les
banques centrales sont pas beaucoup de
levier donc tout ce qui fait en sorte
que y autant de pression à cause des
chaînes d'approvisionnement des chaînes
de valeur la guerre qui fait en sorte
qu'on a des enjeux au niveau de
l'énergie de l'alimentation des engrais
et erreurs pour s'alimenter centrale ont
peu de levier donc ça va prendre la
concertation des gouvernements des
banques centrales falloir utiliser les
bons leviers puis surtout faire
attention de pop empirer la situation du
côté des gouvernements mais c'est sûr
que la hausse des taux et surtout le
signal que les banques centrales
envoient en ce moment c'est très très
très important pour ce type pour les
anticipations d'inflation exactement et
donc si on parle d'augmenter les taux
clément gignac est ce qu on comprend
clairement aujourd'hui qu'on va
augmenter de 5 75 points de base 3 quart
de point de pourcentage de 13 juillet au
clairement parce que on vu la réserve
fédérale qui a fait 75 points de base
évidemment voulu un mois des jeux disait
que c'est un scénario peu probable mais
sont un peu dépassés par les évènements
gardons ça gardons l'esprit gerald que
aux états unis ont pas de lune 115 au
canada le taux est actuellement 1,50 à
1.50 on est encore en période de
stimulation au plein c'est encore
stimule un oubli monétaire pourrait être
entre 2 et 3% déjà donc clairement on va
en voir sur moder réserve fédérale dont
certains une hausse de 60 et que moins
cinq ans sont et 15 points de base
excusez moi et clairement comme la
réserve fédérale faut aller au delà du
tournoi et fouras et au delà 3% au cours
des prochains jours ce matin gérons pas
world le gouverneur le président de la
réserve fédérale aux états unis a
reconnu que la force du mouvement est
flat sioniste le l'a surpris finalement
au cours de la dernière année eq la
hausse des taux pourrait créer une
récession miam ci est ce que ce que les
banques centrales nous mène en récession
c'est la grande question sera grande
crainte depuis le début puis plus les
banques attendait avant de monter les
taux bas plus à fait que maintenant les
augmentations doivent être vigoureuse
est élevé parce que l'inflation on
commence à voir que les gens ne
l'anticipent on commence à avoir dans
les salaires donc avoir de plus en plus
difficiles à ralentir et donc oui le
risque est bien réel d'une récession du
moins d'un ralentissement économique je
pense qu'on est plus rendu à savoir à
quel point ça va ralentir que s'il va y
avoir un ralentissement c'est sûr tu
peux avoir un ralentissement économique
est-ce qu'on va être en récession je ne
sais pas parce qu'il ya d'autres
éléments qui viennent aussi complexifier
la donne le fait qu'il ya énormément d
épargne accumulée dans le système 60
milliards au québec 300 milliards
environ au canada oui donc à quel point
ça va venir changer la donne qui
complexifie la donne comme les
consommateurs vont dépenser cette
épargne est ce que ça va être rapide ça
va être long les entreprises ont des
profits accumulés aussi en 2021 pour
toutes mais certaines de manière
générale il y en a plus et donc comment
tout se savonne jerry ça va être très
très très intéressant su exactement donc
de l'argent encore à dépenser donc ça ça
peut alimenter la demande et donc les
taux d'intérêt doivent augmenter
beaucoup clément gignac est ce que ces
hausses de taux d'intérêt par les
banques centrales par la réserve
fédérale nous amène en récession mais en
fait totalement avec un milieu quand
même beaucoup de nuances a mené puis
d'une sait jamais la même récession on y
parlait longévité ni par ses profondeurs
cette fois ci on peut être optimiste que
cette récession là pour être peut-être
moins pour forme moins sévère que celle
de 2008 parce que le système bancaire
reste très bien capitalisée donc c'est
une erreur de politique monétaire avec
les chaînes d'approvisionnement qui
pourrait s'améliorer avec la réduction
des contraintes que le duel à kovy du
côté de la chine avec aussi un
ralentissement économique la baisse du
prix des matières premières finalement
on pourrait avoir une récession sans
avoir nécessairement une poussée du taux
de chômage je m'explique il ya quand
même canada 1 million de postes qui sont
pas comblés au québec je pense que mieux
le sait mieux que moi c'est 280 minsep
pourra dire que quelqu'un pourrait
perdre son emploi exemple dans le
secteur de la construction mais avoir un
autre opportunité dans un autre secteur
donc peut-être le taux de chômage même
si on avait une récession ce serait
peut-être un tout chemin une récession
qui ne serait pas compagnie d'une
poussée du taux de chômage contrairement
aux récessions précédentes intéressant
par ailleurs là on cherche des solutions
on parle beaucoup de la banque centrale
puis on comprend que la banque centrale
a tardé à agir on reconnaît les erreurs
on a été surpris il avait agi rapidement
du côté des gouvernements
il ya l'alberta qui prolonge sa baisse
de taxes sur l'essence jusqu'au mois de
septembre
hier françois legault encore aujourd'hui
qui a évoqué un chèque supplémentaire
pour les québécois en décembre puis a
parlé d'une ouverture à une baisse
d'impôts en 2023 puis à dubaï donne aux
états unis qui propose une suspension de
la taxe sur l'essence pendant trois mois
mi-homme ci est ce que ces mesures sont
appropriées ou viennent amplifier
l'inflation mais si ça je pense que moi
je commence à voir une nouvelle crainte
par rapport à l'inflation nulle
l'inflation pendant la pandémie vu que
les consommateurs se sont mis à se
tourner vers la les libyens à consommer
plus de biens qui avait pas de service
culêtre gouvernementale après on a eu le
phénomène l'inflation plus à cause de la
guerre en ukraine sur l'essence
d'engrais les matières une alimentation
et hétéros mélo ou pour avoir une
troisième source d'inflation se serait
l'inflation électorale puis celle là me
fait peur aussi parce que ça va venir
avec des promesses l'aude et des
surenchères de promesse de redistribuer
d'argent puis de baisser les impôts de
geler des tarifs mais l'on vaut créé
d'autres distorsions qui va venir plexi
fier le travail des banques centrales
parce qu'au lieu de baisser la demande
l'on veut la stimuler comme en donnant
des chèques à tout le monde c'est pour
ça qu'il faut agir c'est ce qu'il faut
soutenir les gens plus faibles revenus
mais il faut que ce soit ciblée pour les
ennemis pour les gens à faible salaire
et le terrain et donc oui effectivement
un danger inflationniste avec ses
promesses non est ce que les
gouvernements alimente l'inflation kemin
m qu' il s' hautement risqué au québec
claire mains puisque si on regarde
l'impact des mesures qui ont été pris au
dernier budget c'est quand même et qui
venait de 0.8 % du pib québécois comme
stimulus dans le fond c'est est
critiquée que ce 500 $ là soit plutôt
généraliser je pensais 6 millions dans
les 6 points 4 millions de contribuables
on devrait cibler davantage à ceux qui
sont les plus démunis quant à des
approches de de baisse de la taxe sur
l'essence je pense ça serait une erreur
en fait ce qu'on ferait c'est que on
fait juste retardé pour l'un de la
transition énergétique on lance des
mauvais signaux donc vaut mieux avoir
des mesures ciblées aux plus démunis oui
comment des gens faut vraiment que ce
soit ciblée aux plus démunis et plus de
mini ou les retraités qui sont qui est
touchant les suppléments de la pension
de vieillesse parce que faut pouvoir
garder à l'esprit que les plus démunis
et souvent les retraités cee onu si on
regarde l'épicerie c'est un pourcentage
de leurs dépenses d'un montant way
justificatifs que les mieux nantis donc
c'est eux qu'on doit viser et on doit
surtout pas avec des baisses générales
des impôts qui dans le fond viendra tiré
d'un jean bleu band ce cadeau ce qui se
traduirait par des taux d'intérêt
supérieurs comment on aide les gens avec
la facture d'épicerie c'est c'est la
base même si que qu'est ce qu'on fait on
est rendu à 10 % d'inflation à
l'épicerie mais c'est ça moi je pense
qu'il ya deux façons de le voir est ce
qu on essaie de contrôler les prix où on
essaie de faire des compensations au
niveau des revenus moi je pense que
dalle ips côté la compensation des
revenus pour les personnes pour qui
c'est vraiment un enjeu donc à plus
faible revenu c'est la meilleure façon
que tout se mette à essayer de geler des
prix puis d'essayer d'anticiper parce
que quand on y va sur leur venue au
moins on laisse les gens faire des choix
adaptés leur consommation qui prend des
décisions en fonction du prix et donc je
pense que ça donne beaucoup plus de
flexibilité ça peut être ponctuelle on
peut les ajuster on a des crédits
d'impôt solidarité on a des boucliers ce
qu on a tout plein d'outils fiscaux au
québec qu'on peut utiliser on sait que
le régime fiscal aux sites indexés donc
les allocations les prestations et home
depot tout souhaite indexer mais un
décalage dans le temps donc ça reflète
plus l'inflation de l'année antérieure
et donc le gouvernement doit venir
compense east pour combler cet écart
mais il faut pas non plus allé beaucoup
trop loin parce qu'on veut juste perdre
au change avec l'augmentation plus forte
des to 7,7 pour ça aujourd'hui et on va
terminer là tu clément gignac est ce
qu'on va plus haut que ceux-là
malheureusement oui je pense comme au
départ suivi de pourcin vous savez juste
le mois dernier la hausse une balle de 6
15 et ça a été un point 1 % de hausse et
la hausse mensuelle la plus élevée en 30
ans donc malheureusement va dépasser
vite mais je te petit mis ce que promet
comme les mines et gérard a mentionné
plus tôt aujourd'hui que promène le
sommet de l'inflation c'est cet été avec
le ralentissement économique on va voir
et surtout l'amélioration des chaînes
d'approvisionnement qu'on commence déjà
décelé du côté de la chine mais quand on
parle de la hausse des taux d'intérêt
qu'on voit les niveaux d'inflation qu'on
parle de 8%
et là aussi on commence à voir les prix
des maisons qui commencent à baisser
également y la chute des marchés un
moment donné là notre psychologie de
consommateurs mia est affectée puis on
imagine que la confiance de baisser et
que la consommation et que la demande
doit baisser puis que l'inflation va
rebaisser mais je pense que c'est ça
l'objectif c'est d'abord un phénomène où
est-ce qu'on voit se dire comme
consommateur c'est déjà commencer cette
attitude canada fait une enquête auprès
des canadiens puis ça montre que les
gens déjà majoritairement commencé à
changer leur façon de consommer chercher
les rabais les soldes reporter certaines
décisions d'achat peter plus seul but
des banques centrales en ce moment donc
oui c'est ce qui devrait arriver et donc
ça devrait faire en sorte que les taux
baissent puissions l'inflation reste si
on regarde les prévisions de la plupart
des économistes il anticipe qu'on voit
ça va être géré ça veut tout contrôler
mais moi je pense quand même qu'on
considère que c'est possible qu'on vivre
dans un monde les prochaines années avec
une inflation qui est plus élevé que 1
3% voilà bon vous étiez passionnant
merci miom si merci clément gignac
bienvenu.merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
r d